Jersey Shore star Angelina Pavan Nick
tied the knot to Chris Lehren Jorah on
Wednesday but apparently the big day
wasn't all fairytale bliss as cameras
were rolling of course this is according
to an eyewitness at the event
Angelina's bridesmaids which included
some of the other female cast members of
the show gave a speech roasting Angelina
in front of her new husband and guests
and she was not having it put the seat
belt on because they gonna need that
he's gonna need two seat belts buckle up
according to the eyewitness Angelina
left the reception and when she came
back she was screaming at the producers
who were there filming the wedding and
wouldn't talk to the girls
Angelina's co-stars Deena Cortese Jenni
JWoww Farley and Snooki all served as
bridesmaids in the event despite JWoww
and Angelina's falling out on this
season of Jersey Shore family vacations
let's take the old memories Angelina and
throw them out and like now I'm ready to
create new ones
et exclusively broke the news that the
33 year old Jersey Shore star tied the
knot to Chris in a Wednesday ceremony at
the Parc Chateau Estate and Gardens
[Music]